hey guys
code vlogs episode 7 still working on
ancient archer version 6.
it has been a pretty interesting
experience of course in the previous
episode we were on this core chaos
branch here we're no longer on that
branch it was a good experiment i
implemented pretty much all the useful
stuff from it into the main one already
those core features being well i guess
as you kind of as we kind of went
through those episodes you heard it but
mainly the multi windowing and fixing up
a few things with that package manager
and there were a lot of structural tests
the windowing is all coming in i'm
bringing it under os interface probably
going to rename this renderer folder
view at some point or something along
those lines because i think that makes
sense
but currently right now i'm just working
on the front end and making sure
everything hooks up correctly but once
this is all done
the great thing about this
is we're going to be able to launch
multiple windows and have
user specific controls and stuff going
on on each window
so that just opens up a lot of
capabilities for really cool stuff and
applications that you could make with
this because being able to full screen
something on each monitor and have your
own specific controls going on you could
basically make like you know those cool
movie interfaces they do where it looks
like something you've never seen yeah
you could make something like that
because
you could fully just set it up exactly
how you want with as many windows as you
want and doing whatever you want on each
window and all your specific controls so
it just gives it a lot of variety of
uses but i know this was like this sort
of feature was classically used and i
think one of the command and conquers
where you could have a second window pop
up that would be like a map of what you
got going on i could be totally wrong on
the game but there was some game that
did this
maybe it was supreme commander or
something anyway you could have a map
of what's going on
on a second monitor and it would just
pop it up in a second window so you
could do stuff like that i don't see
that in games anymore usually it's just
one big full screen
and they do everything there that's cool
and all but i just want the extra
capabilities because
well
personally i just want to use the
capabilities and i think it'll be cool
to play around with and i'm looking
forward to making stuff
that uses them them being the
multi-window feature
all right well a lot of restructuring to
do
and it's not going to be too bad it
looked pretty intimidating but after i
took a couple days off and like rested
it suddenly
looks a lot less daunting notably i want
to cut out some old features that are
completely useless like this
non-spammable keys timeout thing i had
going on this is actually entirely
useless because
this is for the end user to design sure
you can have it in the engine whatever
but ultimately just take some space for
something that's more of an end user
decision because they can just use your
standard
non-spam
yeah
the opposite of this the the normal one
that just registers as many keys as you
press they can just use that and they
can program in their own timeouts if
they want
so we'll just leave that up to the end
user and not add that it's kind of
useless when i thought about it there's
more i thought about it the more i was
just like
this really has no point
if they don't use it it's just here for
no reason and if they want to use it
they should just implement their own
cooldowns these are the things you can't
you just learn from
making these mistakes
and it's important to make mistakes
if you're having trouble advancing
the best advice i can give you is go try
and make mistakes
rest read
come back later it'll just keep getting
easier and easier every time you do and
that goes for everything including
programming
at this point the task work has actually
become rather menial the hard thinking
is mostly done at least for a little bit
and basically all i'm doing is i'm going
through this entire header file which is
quite large 200 lines it's the entire
front end of what's available to the end
user so it's naturally it's a lot of
stuff and it's probably only going to
grow but we want to refine it to be as
efficient and
intuitive as possible is really cool the
goal but
you know that comes with time it hasn't
shirts so all we're doing now is we're
going through these functions
and we're making sure they're in the h
archer.cpp which is our
kind of main
ties everything together type file
uh the loop the controls the windowing
all that
and i've decided to go for now with a
system of a list of windows kind of like
we had
in the core chaos branch
and with this list of windows we can
keep track of instances running
and anytime we initialize a new window
we'll just increment these
and they also use some global controls
because we don't want to create separate
controls for each they're just going to
come from the os
and that's basically about it
as far as that goes so yeah a lot of
menial work of going through all this
straightening out every single one of
these functions uh removing stuff we
don't need anymore stuff like that
the thoughts on all the shaders is done
for now i figured out a system of doing
that
i'm not sure if i recorded all that talk
but basically i was considering how to
do the default shaders and i decided to
just put a file on the root level
called default shaders and basically
it's very simple it just initializes
them if they're not initialized but this
way
we can use
i'll show it here it makes a little more
sense
we can use this file and essentially we
have
these static variables
so
there's some interesting thing
about class static variables
so normally when you declare a static
global like out here
it's only accessible in that file you
try to x turn it and use it it won't let
you but if you're doing it in a class
it can be it can be used outside
by just including the header
so that's sort of an interesting thing i
use it for
the opengl stuff as well it's very
similar
i know a lot of people don't recommend
this but
this works and there's a way to make
sure i don't replicate things it's
essentially a singleton
uh class except we don't have to do the
whole singleton uh get and and all that
stuff because normally with singleton
all these are just normal functions and
you have a public function that's like
uh
what would it be it would be default
shaders star
get
instance or something like that right
i don't know if you know this already
but this function would be static and
everything else would not be and then
you would
have to use this every time and this
creates the instance
so just making everything static is
somewhat of a different way of doing the
singleton pattern
and i have no idea if it's best practice
i just like it because it's very nice to
look at
and very easy to see and you
just not having to do the get instance
every time
is amazing
that's
for some reason that gets old to me
after a while
although
just to for clarity
i'm not 100 sure that this is better
so uh yeah discuss if you will
but really ultimately the point of that
whole little lecture there
was that uh i just wanted people to kind
of be aware
of that and see what people think
and to also say i'm done working on that
and i'm going to get back to all this
basically getting rid of all these red
marks and
making sure all these functions i'll do
one of them uh just as an example so the
next one we want to do is run so i'm
just going to do a search over here
because this file is huge and messy
and i'm going to grab this entire wrong
function
and we're going to go back up to the top
and basically i'm keeping them in order
so we should see
the very top
first function should be init there it
is
the next function i guess i'll collapse
this for now since we're done with it
the next function will be run
and so on and we're going to go do that
for all these so all these already exist
just need to copy paste them a little
bit clean them up some make sure they
all work
double check that all these variables
that they're supposed to work with are
correct
and as our new structure may have missed
saying something about the windows so
the windows get an id
and these ids need to be managed in case
you close a window all the ids need to
update appropriately because they are an
index into the list of windows yeah so
list a list doesn't have random access
it's going to make this window switching
a tiny bit slower
but i'm not sure if it's going to matter
even with a ton of windows
okay so the run function yeah we look at
it
we check instance windows in this case
it's now what did i change it to just
damn window i'll change the name later
so a cool thing about this
you'd never have to worry about names
if you're stuck on a name don't worry
about it just name it whatever because
later when it's all working and done you
can just control rr or whatever your
rename feature is
and type its new name and it changes all
of them so it's not like i have to worry
about this in window being wrong or this
instance running being wrong
but it just doesn't matter
this is dot empty
there's no window
or i guess in this case now that we're
doing the whole instance thing we need
to make sure
that
the window
that we're looking for
is correct
so it would be like if windows window
does size a better name than window
because that kind of makes me think of
the windows os but actually it's just
like a an actual window you know program
window like like this
and window.size if it's greater then
what would it be would be instances
running
for instance running it's going to save
one on the first one and the size would
also be
one if one running so yeah there we go
no window in it yet
on this instance that's what that should
mean if you get negative five so yeah
we're just going to go down through all
these
fix these all up
and we need to make sure this axis is
the right one
it's actually rather important so this
is the slow part because you can't just
use
when access like this and window id
you can't just do this on a list
that's the big downside so if we use a
vector and we can use a vector here
we just have to consider
how it grows
and it being static might affect that
but the way a list grows isn't gonna
well i gotta think about this more i
don't wanna say too much so yeah that's
basically what we're doing though just
going through and fixing all this
so yeah i'm going to have to iterate
through a little bit and get to this
window uh to do that every while loop is
actually bad so maybe we would go we'll
go to vector i guess you'll find out in
the next episode all right well thanks
for watching uh
episode seven here
day seven
of the vlogs hope you're all doing well
i appreciate you guys all the support
and i'll see you around matt go tech
tutorials over and out peace
[Music]